hello my name is eberhard kuhn i am a
marketing manager at shimatsu scientific
instruments
and i'll be talking about know what you
grow a closer look
at cannabis and hemp testing
no matter what job i do i always want to
have the right tool for the right job
so i could take a hammer to drive this
screw into a piece of wood but i
wouldn't do that i could use an
adjustable wrench which probably works a
little better but still wouldn't
a screwdriver ultimately be the you know
the better choice
or better yet a cordless drill if i had
to do a lot of
screws of course that's not the only
thing i'm ever going to do
so in my toolbox i don't just have one
tool i have
multiple tools and the same is true in
the cannabis lab
so you can see here there are a lot of
different analyses that people do
with cannabis such as you know potency
or terpenes to pesticides and heavy
metals and each one of those
tests each one of those analyses has a
best tool
so here's your toolbox if you will so
this is what a modern cannabis qc lab
will look like
and you can do these type of tests that
are these are the seven most
common tests that people do which is the
the potency profiling which is the
cannabinoids
and the terpene profiling but also uh
pesticide screening residual solvents
heavy metals
mica talks and then finally moisture
content
so let's go around the the lab
and see what uh what each of those tools
will do for us so let's start with our
hplc for
cannabinoids or potency
now you can have an hplc like the one on
the left with lots of
plumbing and tubes going around
or you can have a nice compact uh unit
like the one on the right which we call
the cannabis
analyzer that has everything
self-contained
in itself so and it has you know program
that gives you a nice
output with all the information on your
sample chromatograms and so forth
and then it gives you nice quantitative
results so
you can have all your cannabinoids
individually
or you can have a total for the thc and
the total of cbd
and you can customize these reports but
that's the nice thing is you have a
dedicated instrument that does the
analysis and then gives you
a nice concise data report
now there are three modes of operation
there is one it's the
uh the high sensitive the high
throughput mode
which if you need to really crank
through a lot of uh
samples then there is the high
sensitivity mode which is the one that's
most used in most of the cannabis
labs and then there is the high
resolution one that's really more for
r d purposes so if you are looking at a
new cultivar for instance and you're
trying to see the
the high sensitivity one like i said is
the most popular one because it gives
you a good
uh trace level determination
so four years ago this is what you might
have seen with the high throughput
method
and you know you get ten cannabinoids in
uh
eight minutes with the high sensitivity
min
uh method you get 11 cannabinoids in
10 minutes and with the high resolution
minutes you get 11 cannabinoids in
30 minutes now it's a little longer run
time but you can see that you have
perfect baseline
a resolution of all the cannabinoids now
that was four years ago
since then things have changed the lists
have grown as as you all know but also
some of the technology has evolved so
today
we can do 18 cannabinoids so in the high
resolution minute
a method and then actually do it in a
little bit less time
the high throughput method again we
stayed the same at eight minutes but
we nearly doubled the number of
cannabinoids that can be run in that
same time
and like i said for our most popular one
the high sensitivity method today
it is 21 cannabinoids and it's a little
bit longer but you can see that you can
get very nice
quantitation of these 21 cannabinoids
so the point is that you know four years
ago
compared to today so there are some
changes so
what's nice with the cannabis analyzer
is that you have the software and you
get
updates to the software that then allow
you to
always have the right method for the
latest
regular latest requirements for the
number of cannabinoids
and the other nice thing is you can
actually look at it from your smartphone
you can check the system status the
chromatogram process
progress so from your smartphone you
could be anywhere and
take a look at your analysis
okay now let's move over to our gcms
and now we'll look at terpenes
there are a lot of terpenes in in
cannabis over 200 have been found so far
and there is some synergistic effect
that you get with the cannabinoids it's
often called the
the entourage effect now
terpenes are part of a larger family of
compounds
known as essential oils and essential
oils are used in aromatherapy
so in and by themselves
terpenes already have a health benefit
and if you combine that
with the health benefit of the
cannabinoids you get that really that
holistic cannabis experience by having
the cannabinoids and the
terpenes with their entourage effect
so let's look at this particular
cultivar that has
22 percent thc and then it has
some terpenes there pinene and
caryophylline
and those percentages the 40 and 25
are not off the total flower that's
actually off the
terpene content but the pinene as you
can see here it's got anti-inflammatory
antibacterial
effect so it does offer those additional
health benefits
compare that to this cultivar that's the
same male
different female so you have about the
same
uh thc 24
but you have a different uh terpene
profile in this case you have
mercy which is the the predominant um
terpene and it's a sedative and
anti-insomnia so
it will give you a much more relaxing
experience
than the previous cultivar would have so
the the terpenes play a big role
in how the uh
cannabis the interacts with your with
your body
so for analysis again we use our
headspace gc or gcms
and we can do very nicely this is a list
of i think 38
terpenes that you can see there very
nicely uh
resolved and analyzed and quantitative
okay so moving on now to
uh residual solvents in this case we're
using a
headspace gc
so like many of the analyses
in the cannabis it's a it's a list-based
approach so in this case we're looking
at the oregon list which is about
35 residual solvents and you can see
with our headspace gc we can very easily
separate those 35 residual solvents
and we can even do the uh california
list which is a
20 residual solvents and you can see
here very nicely again excellent
resolution good quantitation
in the picture you actually see a
headspace
ms and you can actually
combine that if you have the headspace
gcms then you can do
the terpenes and the residual solvents
in a single run so you can actually use
the same tool but do two different
types of analysis so you get a two for
one special if you will
okay next we'll move to our icpms which
we will use to analyze for heavy metals
why do we worry about hemming heavy
metals well plants in general
bioaccumulate metals from the soil
and you know hemp in cannabis is really
no
no exception to that and that can be
positive because you can get uh
a good nutrients from the soil and you
can get
good metals if you will uh potassium
iron calcium and things
but at the same time you also get some
of the toxic metals and
in this case we want to analyze them by
icp ms inductively coupled
uh plasma mass spectrometry and usually
when people talk about heavy metals they
talk about the big four
lead cadmium mercury
and arsenic
and the regulatory agencies like the usp
and fda they establish permissible daily
exposure limits
and you can see those here in table one
you know for the arsenic cadmium lid
and mercury and they're in the uh
low uh ppm range
so when we did the analysis of a
cannabis flower
you know we compared that to those
limits on the bottom row now of table
two
you can see those limits from table one
uh for comparison then to the matrix and
you can see in the top row when we look
at matrix
that the levels we found in the cannabis
flower
are actually significantly below
the admissible daily exposure limit so
we don't need to worry about heavy
metals in
that particular cannabis flower
okay now we'll turn to our lcms
triple quad in the front here and first
of all
use it to analyze for pesticides
like any crop
cannabis hat is susceptible to attacks
by
pests so a little bug so people use
pesticides to protect the crop
and then we'll have to analyze for those
pesticides
historically much of the
pesticide analysis was done by gcm sms
but more recently a lot of it has
shifted towards lc
ms triple quad and it has to do with uh
the volatility of the pesticides uh the
polarity of the pesticides
but more pesticides are amenable to elsi
than there
are to to chisel
and in fact we can do hundreds of
pesticides with lc
msms you can see here 211 pesticides
uh very easily done with with an lcms
triple quad the bigger challenge really
is
keeping up with the ever-evolving
pesticide
lists as you can see here now each state
has
has a different list and it started in
colorado and got to oregon at 59 and
then
california said well oregon i'll see
your 59 and i'll race you to 66.
and then canada goes 66 hey well
we can do 96 so canada's starting a list
of 96
pesticides and then currently
aoac international is working on a list
of
104 pesticides and not only
is it a larger list or more compounds
but they're also looking to lower the
limit of quantitation
and the limit of uh residue
residue detection so
the point i'm making is that these lists
are expected to continue to evolve
you know the laboratory capabilities
change instrument capabilities change
uh risk assessments regulations
laws so keep an eye on that rather than
worry about whether the instrument can
handle
instrument can if you have an lc triple
quad ms
it can handle 104 it can handle 204 so
but just make sure that you are aware of
which list you
are running
just like with the gcms with the
headspace we can do
a second analysis with the uh lc-ms
triple quad
in this case we're looking at
microtoxins
so mycotoxins and their carcinogenic
type aflatoxins their type of mold
that is present in a lot of plants
including
cannabis and so there's testing required
for the the four aflatoxins b1
b2 g1 and g2 and then there's also
mycotoxin
oculotoxin a that needs to be analyzed
in most
cases what's nice is as i mentioned
because we already did the pesticides on
the lcms we can do those combined so in
this case you see that we have the
oregon pesticide list
plus the microtoxin plus the aflatoxins
all in a single run now if you need a
little more
sensitivity for the aflatoxins and
microtoxins then
a conventional hplc with the
fluorescence detector will give you a
little better sensitivity down to the
single digit part per billion
range as you can see here in the in the
table where we quantitated the
the data
okay so now let's look at uh moisture
testing
that's our little moisture testing is
sitting there in the corner
mold and bacteria can really thrive
in a moist environment and of course we
don't want that especially in prolonged
storage
and the data have shown that the moles
can really
proliferate when the moisture level
exceeds 12 percent
so with a moisture balance you can very
easily
determine the moisture level and what's
nice about this test too is that it is
non-destructive meaning that you can
do a moisture analysis test and then
take
these the the product and put it back on
the shelf
just have to make sure especially if
you're going to store the product for
any length of time
i have to assure that the total moisture
content
is less than 12 otherwise you uh
could run the danger of seeing some mold
growth
and now for something completely
different brought to you by
the ministry of silly walks
a convenient and tasty
way to enjoy or administer uh
cannabis cannabinoids is through edibles
and they could be you know the brownies
cookies and everything and there
and they ever popular gummy bears now
edibles are then a type of food and
texture
in food is is quite important and
we have a certain perception of texture
and it's based on you know maybe a prior
experience so if you look at the
popcorn you know we have a certain
expectation and we buy popcorn although
it's nuts on the bottom right
i want them to be hard and you know like
a peanut be a little softer than an
almond for instance
when you take a bite of an apple there's
a certain texture that you expect you
don't want it to be mealy and soft but
kind of crisp and juicy
and even when it comes to chocolate you
know a chocolate cake
for instance you want that to be soft
and moist
while a piece of chocolate you want that
to be a little firm
and dry of course and and then of course
the gummies you know you have a certain
expectation on the chewiness
of the gummies so
texture is actually a sensory property
of a food
and there was a scientist dr elena
chechnyak
who developed this texture profile
analysis and so she correlated some of
these
characteristics like hardness
adhesiveness
elastic quality to certain sensory
experiences that someone will have
eating the food
and we can actually quantitate that so
we can do a texture profile analysis and
it's basically
looking at the mechanical properties by
taking a food in this case we have these
samples of edibles the gummies
and you can see in the middle picture
you know you have to come you have the
plunger come down
and then they started to squish the
gummy i mean i i love these instruments
because they're so
fun to watch you can actually see what
what's happening
but we you know we squish the gummy
deform it
and then there is a lot of math and
algorithms that happen
uh behind the scenes and you can then
get quantitative output of
characteristics like
hardness cohesiveness chewiness and you
don't need to worry about any of that
math or anything that's all part of the
software and it does all that behind the
scenes
but then you get a nice quantitative
output and
that's really important if you're
developing a new
edible and you're trying out
new additives new formulations and
this gives you a way to quantify
a number for what you're the consumer
then may
describe it as soft or hard or chewy
so you can see that here and this is
becomes important so
in this case we're looking at two
different brands of medicated gummies
and you can see that brand b has a
higher firmness and chewiness compared
to brand
a so if you think about what that means
is that you have to chew brand b
longer to get it into a consistency
that's suitable for swallowing so it's
the mastication
and excuse me that may not be
as critical if it's safe for
recreational use for adults
but if this is a medicated gummy that's
prescribed to
say a small child then that process of
chewing it and breaking it down to a
consistency where the child can swallow
it
that becomes uh more important and so
it's nice to know that you can
quantitate that
ahead of time as part of your product
development
now this is a test that's not uh
not typical for your cannabis labs but i
just wanted you to be aware of
that there is a instrumentation that
allows you to
quantitate the texture of
the edibles so
which then you know brings me back to
having the right tool for the for the
right job you know there's these
seven analyses they're color-coded here
the ones in
in the dark blue at the top those are
the desirable
constituents ingredients of the cannabis
the cannabinoids and the terpenes
the ones in reds are the ones that you
don't want in there but
you still have to check for them and
then of course you have the moisture at
the end
point being there's a right tool for
any of these type 7 analyses and some of
the tools can be used multiple times
like the lc triple quad ms
pesticides microtoxins or the gcms
for the terpenes and the residual
solvents
so that's uh all i have for today i want
to
thank you for your attention if you have
any questions
feel free to email me at ercoon
shimatsu.com
or you can go to www.growyourlab.com and
there's
you'll find a lot of good information
about cannabis and hemp analysis
on that on that website and with that
again i want to thank you and bye bye